There are many popular hash algorithms, and of course, you can write your own,
but you should never write your own.
The first lesson you'll learn in CS387 is don't write your own,
at least for our purposes.
Of course, if you're building a hash table, you can do whatever you want,
but if you're going to use it for security purposes, don't write your own.
Then if you want to learn how to make a hash table, knock yourself out.
Of course, somebody has probably done it better, but hey, you never know.
So anyways, some popular algorithms are CRC32,
which is basically designed for checksomes.
If you were to send somebody a bunch of data, like a big file,
you might also include a CRC of that file, and that is basically just a simple way
to verify that you've got the entire file, and it's not corrupted
because you can send a hash easier than you can send a whole file.
You can copy and paste a hash. It's just a few bits.
You can verify that the file you received has the same CRC as the file they sent.
Then you don't have to verify bit for bit that you have the correct file.
So CRC is really fast. Its really only purpose is for doing checksomes.
Basically, creating a hash of a large file.
It's security properties are not very good.
It's very easy to find what we call a collision,
which is when 2 things hash to the same value,
which is the whole point of a hash is that we can get a different value for almost
anything that we're going to hash.
Now obviously, if the size of the input is substantially greater than the size of the output,
yes, there are going to be collisions.
The whole point is that it's hard to find them, and with CRC32, it's very easy to find them.
The reason you'd use CRC is because you don't care about collisions,
you just care about speed, and CRC is very fast.
The most popular hashing algorithm out there is still md5,
which used to be used because it was both fast-ish--not as fast as CRC32,
but pretty fast and people thought it was pretty secure, except it's not.
Md5 has been broken repeatedly over the last few years, and it's very easy to find
md5 collisions.
Given an x that hashes into a y, it's very easy given this y to find another x
that hashes into it, which is, as you'll see, a big problem.
So we won't be using md5 for much at all in this class.
Well, it has its use cases, right?
If you have a limited input, it's hard to find a collision.
There's certain a class of attacks, making x longer and longer and longer,
that's a really easy way to find a collision in md5.
But if you limit the length of x, then you don't have to worry too much about that vulnerability.
So anyway, just keep that in mind.
When you really care about the data, don't use md5.
The second most popular hash is called sha1.
This is not as fast, but it's fairly secure, just now are we starting to hear demonstrations
of people finding collisions in sha1.
It's still pretty good. It's actually the second most widely used hash behind md5.
But for things going forward, you should really use something like for example, sha256,
which is as you might guess just kind of a bigger version of sha1.
It's actually not, The algorithm, I believe, is changed as well.
So let's say this one is secure-ish, and this one is pretty good.
It's going to take some time.
Now, of course, the trade off is speed.
So the better the hashing algorithm right now, the slower it is.
So these are, basically, organized in cost and in security,
so no big surprise there that there's an inverse correlation between cost and security.
But that's the name of the game.
So depending on what problem you're working on,
you may need to actually make a decision.
But for our purposes, we're not going to get a whole lot of traffic.
We'll probably use sha256 for most things.
So let me show you how you would use these.